[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen sven voss es
auch dabei für den sport schon genannt
und das sind unsere themen heute
wahlkampf auf der zielgeraden mit
parteitagen schwören sich grüne wie fdp
auf den endspurt ein und wärme noch mal
um wählerstimmen
runden gang mit fragezeichen
überschattet von betrugsvorwürfen geht
die parlamentswahl in russland zu ende
und erfolgreicher tag in aachen beim
chio gewinnt daniel deußer das springen
und isabell werth findet bis uhr
[Applaus]
eine woche vor der bundestagswahl ist
der ausgang offen wie selten so wohl
spd-kandidat olaf scholz als auch unions
konkurrent armin laschet haben nach
umfragen die chance aufs kanzleramt
abhängig ist das auch von den grünen und
der fdp beide könnten kanzler macher
werden je nach koalition und beide
hatten heute noch parteitage patricia
wiedemeier beginnt mit den grünen
die grünen sie bejubeln ihre
kanzlerkandidatin machen sich mut für
den endspurt des wahlkampfs und
beschwören immer wieder dass mehr für
den klimaschutz getan werden muss wenn
jetzt nicht alle weichen auf klimaschutz
gestellt werden dann landen wir in einer
2,7 grad welt und das ist überhaupt nur
der fahrt wenn die klimaziele
eingehalten werden deutschland verpasst
gerade seine klimaziele wieder ein
sozialpakt soll die folgen eines
klimagerechten umbau von wirtschaft und
gesellschaft abfedern durch zum beispiel
mehr weiterbildungs und
qualifizierungsangebote für mitarbeiter
zudem fordert sie wie die spd den
mindestlohn zu erhöhen
deswegen bedeutet ein aufbruch für
soziale gerechtigkeit vor allen dingen
als allererstes dem mindestlohn auf 12
euro anzuheben auch eine
kindergrundsicherung versprechen die
grünen mehr tempo bei der
digitalisierung insgesamt einen aufbruch
die eigentlichen herausforderungen habe
die groko ignoriert im wahlkampf sei
genau das zu selten thema gewesen so
robert habeck sind steckengeblieben in
dämlichen im dummen debatten die von den
politischen mitbewerbern immer wieder
hochgezogen wurden und die eigentliche
diskussion er verstellt haben eine woche
vor der bundestagswahl war hier gar
nicht mehr so viel die rede davon dass
die grünen ins kanzleramt einziehen
sondern eher dass man eine starke grüne
partei in der nächsten regierung brauche
und dafür setzen sie nun im schlussspurt
des wahlkampfs natürlich auf dass
klimaschutz thema aber auch auf soziale
gerechtigkeit nur wer grün wähle der
würde für einen politikwechsel für einen
aufbruch sorgen das war die deutliche
botschaft hier in welcher koalition sie
künftig mitregieren wollen dazu heute
jedoch keine konkrete aussage
auch die fdp geht ohne konkrete
koalitionsaussage in die letzte
wahlkampfwoche allerdings wird wieder
deutlich dass sie am liebsten mit der
union regieren würde am penthin hat mehr
unsere freiheit ist in gefahr die fdp
motiviert sich für den endspurt unsere
wirtschaft ist in gefahr das ziel heute
rote linien für mögliche
koalitionsverhandlungen abstecken das
ziel auch keine koalitions zu oder
absagen treffen selbst wenn das die
union fordert wir schließen aus
steuererhöhungen wir schließen aus
aufweichung der schuldenbremse wir
schließen aus beizutragen zu einem
linksruck in deutschland aber von dieser
union nehmen wir keine anweisungen
entgegen in der klimapolitik will
lindner verbote verhindern setzt
stattdessen auf technologischen
fortschritt eine erhöhung des
mindestlohns kernanliegen der
sozialdemokraten sieht er kritisch
generell herrscht viel skepsis gegenüber
der spd auf der bühne und im saal
erstmal sollten in der linkspartei
absagen das wäre die voraussetzung
ich möchte einen deutschland der mitte
und kein deutschland das nach links
rutscht mir persönlich ist es nicht so
wichtig mit wem wir das tun hauptsache
die liberalen ziele werden umgesetzt in
einer neuen regierungskoalition egal wie
sie aussehen wird lindner lobt armin
laschet kritisiert olaf scholz und
spottet über die grünen an laschet
richtet er die botschaft auch der wahl
zweite könnte ein regierungsbündnis
schmieden ein gedankenspiel dass einige
in der union gerade von sich weisen
während csu mann alexander dobrindt sagt
als zweitplatzierter könnte man doch
kein kanzler stellen baut christian
lindner für genau diesen fall vor seine
präferenz für ein bündnis mit der union
wird sehr deutlich gleichzeitig
vermeidet er es aber die tür zur spd
komplett zuzuschlagen
fünf bündnisse sind gerade laut umfragen
denkbar drei gehen nur mit der fdp die
liberalen gefallen sich in ihrer alten
rolle königsmacher
kurz zu corona gesundheitsminister
sparen hat eine positive bilanz der
bundesweiten impfaktion woche gezogen
der funke mediengruppe sagte er es habe
rund eine halbe million erstimpfungen
gegeben die hälfte davon sei auf die
aktionen zurückzuführen im vergleich zur
vorwoche hat sich die zahl der impfungen
allerdings kaum verändert seit wochen
lassen sich immer weniger menschen gegen
korona impfen in russland geht die
dreitägige parlamentswahl zu ende ein
sieg der kreml partei geeintes russland
gilt als sicher
110 millionen menschen waren zur wahl
aufgerufen eine ernst zu nehmende
opposition war nicht zugelassen
unabhängige beobachter berichten von
massenhaftem wahlbetrug christiansen
die luft ist rein denkt sich diese
wahlhelferin in einem wahllokal in der
region brjansk kurz danach landet ein
dicker batzen wahlzettel in der urne
die wird später beschlagnahmt alle
stimmen annulliert aber sie sehen wie
diese die seit freitag in den sozialen
netzwerken geteilt werden besonders in
der nacht haben wir hinweise bekommen
dass räumlichkeiten in denen die
stimmzettel aufbewahrt werden falsch
versiegelt wurden dass einige leute in
diese räumlichkeiten gekommen sind und
ohne beobachter irgendwas gemacht haben
es sind parlamentswahlen die mit
internationalen standards nicht viel
gemein haben aussichtsreiche
oppositionskandidaten wurden von der
wahl ausgeschlossen oder aus dem land
gejagt opposition und freie medien sehen
sich seit monaten einer repressionswelle
ausgesetzt das ziel die kreml partei
einiges russland soll ihre absolute
mehrheit verteidigen der wahlsieger
steht für viele schon fest der kreml
braucht eine hohe wahlbeteiligung um
sich auf die legitimation des volkes
berufen zu können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
christian sam ist für uns bei der
wahlkommission in moskau es gibt noch
keine ergebnisse christian aber es gibt
tendenzen zur wahlbeteiligung
genau die wahlbeteiligungen die liegt
derzeit bei rund 45 prozent und das ist
nicht wirklich viel vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass diese wahl drei tage lang
gedauert hat entscheiden wird zum
schluss sein wie viel prozent davon die
kreml partei für sich verbuchen kann
denn die wahl gilt auch als eine art
stimmungstest für präsident putin
2024 sind die nächsten
präsidentschaftswahlen und da könnte
wladimir putin erneut als
präsidentschaftskandidat antreten was
zum schluss von dieser wahl eigentlich
bleiben was auch das entscheidende ist
sind die umstände unter denen dieser
wahl jetzt stattgefunden hat wir haben
es im beitrag gesehen und es gibt
massive manipulationsvorwürfe die
wahlkommission hat angekündigt diese zu
prüfen aber auch im vorfeld haben wir
das hier erleben seit monaten die
repressionswelle gegen journalisten
gegen oppositionspolitiker so dass man
nicht wirklich von einer freien und
fairen wahl hier sprechen kann
dankeschön christian seinem live aus
moskau
nach spanien erstmals seit 50 jahren ist
auf der kanaren insel la palma wieder
ein vulkan ausgebrochen und zwar im
nationalpark um reviere im süden der
insel der ausbruch des vulkans wurde
schon seit mehreren tagen befürchtet
nach dem es eine reihe kleinerer
erdbeben gegeben hatte umliegende
ortschaften werden evakuiert die
bevölkerung ist aufgerufen das gebiet zu
meiden
und jetzt zum sport sein mit einer neuen
herausforderung für stefan kurz ja jetzt
ist es offiziell der deutsche u21
erfolgstrainer verlässt den dfb nach
fünf jahren und wird nationaltrainer in
der türkei kunst gewann mit der
deutschen u21 zwei mal den
europameister-titel nun soll er die
türkei zur wm 2022 führen
das erste sonntagsspiel ist durch
leverkusen gewann beim vfb stuttgart mit
drei zu eins und verdrängt die mainzer
von platz 3 und nächstes wm gold für
rennkanuten konrad steiner bei den
weltmeisterschaften in kopenhagen gewann
der berliner diesmal im sprintfinale auf
der 500 meter strecke
dabei knüpfte der 25-jährige an die
hervorragende leistung tags zuvor über
die 1000 meter strecke an gute wasser
wald und sein kraftvoller dreh steuer
schlag auch heute wieder seine trümpfe
in diesem 500 meter finale von beginn an
hält scheint nah dabei die
renngeschwindigkeit hoch und sichern
sich sein zweites gold hier in
kopenhagen
silber im k 2 durch tobias schulz und
martin heller und eine weitere
bronzemedaille für moritz florstadt
rundeten das gute ergebnis des deutschen
kanu verbandes ab
und genau so geht es weiter
erfolgreicher schlusstag für die
deutschen reiterinnen und reiter beim
chio in aachen auf die dressur equipe
war wieder einmal verlass genauso wie
auf springreiter daniel deußer den
weltranglisten-ersten
daniel deußer und seine killer queen
haben den großen preis von aachen
abgeräumt und wie als erstes war im
stechen gelingt ihnen ein fehlerfreier
ritt zu schnell für die übrige
konkurrenz
liegt vor dem us-amerikaner morgen
jetzt ist es wahr dennoch so ein
bisschen sprachlos her
atemberaubend auch der auftritt von
isabelle werth mit dem jungen panthers
den großen dressurpreis mit mehr als 88
prozent punkten der überlegene sieg
damit gewinnt deutschland auf den
nationenpreis vor den niederlanden und
großbritannien
dritter sieg für das deutsche team beim
hamburg triathlon nach den erfolgen von
laura lindemann und tim helwig im einzel
gewannen sie heute gemeinsam mit marlene
gomez islinger und lasse magath riester
in der mixed-staffel gewünscht
dankeschön das wetter wird morgen so
teils aufgelockert teils stark bewölkt
an der ostsee sowie ganz im süden kann
es etwas regnen höchstwerte 12 bis 20
grad in den nächsten tagen eine mischung
aus sonne und wolken ab donnerstag neuer
reden ist das heute journal mit marietta
slomka wie gewohnt um viertel vor zehn
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
wir seinen schuss bis morgen wenn sie
mögen und geben ab armen berlin direkt
untergrund der manager